Speaker 1: All right.
This is a really important debunk.
Ivermectin has become all the rage as a possible
treatment for covid among some Americans,
except there aren't actually any blind, randomized
controlled trials in humans with a placebo
group that prove ivermectin is good for covid
in humans.
Recently, ivermectin got a big publicity boost
because Joe Rogan took it along with multiple
other medications when he got covid about
a week and a half ago.
And then in a recent segment on his show with
comedian Tom Sagara, Rogan cited something
that tons of people are citing.
He said, listen, Japan said, let's use it.
Japan is super conservative on medications,
on elements of medical.
And yet Japan said use ivermectin for covid,
except they actually didn't.
This is a huge red flag debunk that we have
to do.
So let's start with what Joe Rogan said on
his program and then go from there.
Speaker 2: It's it's supposed to have what
is the exact thing it's supposed to do?
There's there's something that I highlighted
and this is obviously I'm not.
A doctor says ivermectin was found to be a
blocker of viral reppert replicates our Eppy,
Elyse, S.A.C., Protos, and this for this human
tmb, our access to I don't know.
But what they didn't highlight is that I got
better.
Yeah, you got better to try to make it seem
as if like I'm doing some wacky that's completely
ineffective.
Right.
CNN was saying that I'm a distributor of misinformation
also.
That was the other thing that happened the
in Tokyo and Japan, which is apparently they're
very conservative about the medication that
the the use and the medications that they
endorse.
But the Tokyo Medical Association chairman
held a live press conference recommending
ivermectin to all doctors for all covered
patients.
Speaker 1: OK, so there's a lot there are
a lot of it we already looked at last week.
Let's focus on the Japan thing.
The the claim is there was this conference,
press conference in Japan.
And at the press conference they said doctors
should use ivermectin.
And this is being endlessly repeated.
It's being endlessly posted.
The same article keeps getting posted.
And the truth is that that video is from February.
It's being posted now as if this is a new
development based on studies of ivermectin.
It's not OK.
The video has been floating around of a chairperson
and the Japanese Medical Association saying
we recommend doctors in Japan use ivermectin
to treat covid-19.
It's being posted now late August, early September,
as if it was just filmed and is based on recent
data.
It was filmed in February.
It's not new.
The video is from before.
There was really any investigation of ivermectin
for covid-19.
It is now seven months later.
Japan has not approved of ivermectin to be
used to treat covid-19.
And in fact, after the February statement
that people have been posting, Japan's Health
Ministry's covid-19 treatment guidelines were
revised in July and they put ivermectin on
a list of drugs whose efficacy and safety
have not been established.
That's July.
So the guidelines refer to reports that the
drug does not improve mortality for covid.
It does not shorten hospitalization for covid.
It does not accelerate reducing viral loads
in patients with mild symptoms.
So first of all, the FDA, the Waco and other
organizations, they have opinions about ivermectin,
which you could look at.
So already saying we're going to ignore all
of these opinions and just look at what Japan
said.
That's already strange.
Like if you're going to choose to ignore all
of it and say, I'm only going to look at what
Japan is doing, you're already cherry picking.
But even if you say I'm going to only look
at Japan, the most recent statement from Japan
is this doesn't work.
Ivermectin doesn't work.
So it does when people post that do not be
swayed by it.
Now, one other thing.
In the segment, Rogan says, I took ivermectin
and I got better.
This is the epitome of specious reasoning.
I would love to be back on Joe's program and
to talk about this.
You have a condition which most people recover
from, right?
Like remember, the death rate overall of covid
depends on how many people never get tested.
But we believe that that the death rate is
somewhere between zero point eight percent
and one point five percent roughly in terms
of the infection fatality rate.
It includes the fact that some people never
get tested.
Most people recover from covid regardless
of what medications they take.
When you take ivermectin and as they throw
Meyssan and monoclonal antibodies and prednisone,
steroids and vitamin drips, there is no possible
way you can attribute one recovery to one
of the things that you took, especially when
most people recover without taking anything.
It's just not an empirical statement.
It's an anecdotal statement.
Now, believe me, I get emails from people
saying, David, why are you against ivermectin?
Why aren't you open to ivermectin?
The second we have a blind, placebo controlled,
randomized controlled trial of ivermectin
that says it works, I will be right there
supporting it.
I said the same thing about hydroxy chloroquine
and lots of other things.
We had the combination of two HIV drugs that
were being looked at, all these things.
A couple of these became politicized and popular,
mostly among the right.
I don't have I'm completely agnostic about
all of these things.
Give me the double blind placebo controlled
trials that say they work for covid.
And I will be right there saying, let's go
ahead and do this.
We do not have that evidence right now for
ivermectin.
People pointing to Japan are focusing on something
said in February when Japan updated their
recommendations in July.
It has to stop.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter
at
David Pakman.